[Music]
i would start with
chess is a thinking game test is a game
of skill
even though it looks boring doesn't mean
it is boring
it is a great game it's my favorite
game also
[Music]
you have materials pieces
16 pieces on both sides your pawns move
on up or two up but it
captures differently than it moves the
knight
moves like an l a rock can move sideways
and forward
that's all the bishop looked at the
diagonal
wait we didn't mention the king and
queen anyway anyway the queen is really
powerful
and if you take the queen it will be
easy for you
to generate
[Music]
the best way to learn chess is to learn
a lot of openings
it's also good to learn tactics that
helps you be a bit more solid player
because i haven't learned all the
strategies yet
but i have learned some my favorite
opening is probably the english attack
i played a sicilian one of our favorite
openings
is sicilian and we landed in december i
like the
fried liver v65
e65 the scotch gambit
it's really hard to win it's not c3 it's
a d4 and then
there's no people who played the london
system usually win
but it's really complicated before it
takes takes
because seasons fried is
disgusting
[Music]
you need bravery to play chess i was a
little scared to play at first when i
get nervous
i like to wiggle my toes breathe and
then hold the air for
30 seconds you play calmly and if you
lose
you're not going to be scared or sad i'm
not
that upset i'm just kind of upset i'm
not super upset
i'm just upset when you lose you learn
from your mistakes
yeah don't like give up it's not like
you're
gonna play bad for the rest of your life
sometimes
he cries when he loses that was a little
baby and you cried
last time you didn't want to play
anymore because you would kind of be
beating you is that correct probably
he thinks if he loses you should give up
chess
yes you can still play and you will
still improve if you win again
you should be good sportsman if we win
we'll be happy but
i do not love your little face you know
how your parents are proud of you when
you win
you could also be proud of yourself i'm
not really trying to be too competitive
i'm just trying to
show myself that i can do this and i
agree with charlotte
a hundred percent
it doesn't matter how old you are how
small you are
just looking like for everybody adults
who don't know how to play chess
shouldn't be scared old people shouldn't
be forced to learn chess but
if they want to learn chess surely they
can they're allowed to even though they
could be doing something else
like playing legos it's not always about
to win trophies
it's about having fun if you have fun
you'll learn more of it
so i think you should ask me why do you
like chess so much it's just a game of
concentration
and that concentration will help me
everything i do
i think chess has taught me brain skills
to help me with other things
in my life i learned how to be
aggressive be more famous
if you play well it teaches you
how to make a plan and making mistakes
or blunders
all you have to do is try again as fast
as you can
chess is very fun so i'll never stop
playing when i win
it gives me a good feeling like i'm good
at chess and i
learn every day chess is not a boring
thing
it's like magic and it's actually
really fun in my opinion
[Music]
[Music]
you